if what I saw is
true war is on its
way you've got to fix this for Loki will
be last
forever
great this entire place is going to be
destroyed we have one shot at this
whatever we do we're playing God what
could we have done
differently lowkey season 2 streaming
October 5th only on Disney Plus in order
to do that I need a low key who remains
so we need to address the fact that you
keep disappearing well I I keep
disappearing we don't have
time you just disappeared I know I can't
keep looking at it cuz it's horrible
what I thought we said didn't know that
bad I was lying it's terrible it looks
like you're being born or dying or both
at the same time it's really it's
freaking me out it's okay painful it's
not that bad I can hand it how does it
look